[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in allen inmitten all der
furchtbaren nachrichten dieser zeit gibt
es das was uns menschen ausmachen sollte
und was das grauen des krieges nun noch
unsinniger erscheinen lässt eine aus
russland stammende familie in dänemark
öffnet ihr haus für flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine und nimmt gleich 16 menschen in
not auf sie werden sich viel zu erzählen
wie überhaupt gespräche jetzt der
einzige vorsichtige hoffnungsschimmer
sind morgen sollen sich der russische
und der ukrainische außenminister
treffen die suche nach einer
friedenslösung
während das morden weiter geht christian
kirsch
am tag vor dem treffen des russischen
und des ukrainischen außenministers
liegt der achtjährige atem schwer
verletzt in einem kinderkrankenhaus in
der nordwestlichen ukraine sein linker
arm wurde amputiert eine bombe tötete
seinen vater und seinem bruder
atem hat seinen bruder und seinen vater
sterben sehen und ich wünsche mir sagt
seine mutter das er das letzte kind ist
dass unter den grausamkeiten dieses
krieges leidet und dass alle
ukrainischen soldaten sicher und leben
nach hause zurückkehren
morgen nun ein treffen der außenminister
vorher heute bislang ungewohnte töne aus
dem russischen ministerium ziel des
krieges sei weder die besetzung der
ukraine noch die zerstörung ihrer
staatlichkeit noch der sturz der
aktuellen führung unter präsident sei
lenski doch was ist dann das ziel dieses
angriffskrieges auch die ukrainische
regierung ließ wissen man kann über
vieles reden über den status der
rebellengebiete im osten der ukraine
über die zukunft der krim ja sogar über
einen möglichen status einstweiliger
neutralität der ukraine
wir haben mögliche lösungen für diese
drei schlüsselprobleme was jetzt
passieren müsste ist dass präsident
putin in einen dialog eintritt in
gespräche stattdessen lebt er in einer
informationsbörse ohne sauerstoff dort
lebt der
vorsichtige annäherung die realität des
krieges ist eine andere trotz
vereinbarter waffenruhe treffen in der
hafenstadt mariupol heute bomben eine
entbindungsklinik schwangere frauen als
ziel ein angriff der eine internationale
welle der empörung auslöst von 17
verletzten ist die rede die klinik in
der eingeschlossenen stadt nach dem
angriff ein trümmerfeld
dringend fordert die ukraine auch eine
feuerpause im norden kiers dort ist eine
hochspannungsleitung zerstört die das
kraftwerk in tschernobyl versorgt die
anlage wird inzwischen von russischen
truppen kontrolliert der strom wird
dringend gebraucht um brennelemente in
abklingbecken zu kühlen
der ukrainische außenminister fordert
die weltgemeinschaft auf druck auf
russland auszuüben ein waffenstillstand
müsse her damit die leitungen repariert
werden können
tag 14 dieses krieges im besetzten
chance und zogen sie auf die straße
zeigten den russen ihre ukrainische
fahne menschen die sich ergeben sehen
anders aus
sanktionen sollen ihr ziel stärker
treffen als die länder die sie verhängen
das ist die idee ein sofortiger
importstopp von russischen
energielieferungen würde aber auch
europa schwer schaden andererseits
dürfen wir putins krieg quasi
mitfinanzieren es ist die wahl zwischen
pest und cholera eine frage die sich in
deutschlands wirtschaft alarmiert stellt
eine frage die uns begleitet beim
leidensweg an die tankstelle eine frage
auf die der energieminister eine antwort
braucht und zwar schnell ich rede gleich
mit ihm erst dominik löschmeister und
die szenarien die uns jetzt drohen die
hoffnung ist extrem kalt minus 162 grad
auf diese temperatur ist gas herunter
gekühlt damit es flüssig das schiff
transportiert werden kann ohne erdgas
aus russland braucht deutschland mehr
flüssiggas den bisher importiert
deutschland 55 prozent seines gases aus
russland gefolgt von norwegen und den
niederlanden ein verzicht auf russisches
gas könnte zu engpässen führen wäre aber
machbar die wärmeversorgung der haushalt
die ist prioritär die sollte garantiert
sein es wird niemanden kalt obwohl es
natürlich dazu beiträgt dass wir mit der
situation klarkommen wenn man die
heizung etwas bunter dreht oder wenn man
anderweitig energie einspart es ist so
dass wir an einigen stellen gas ersetzen
können im stromsektor können wir gas
ersetzen dadurch dass wir gasverstromung
durch kohle verstromung ersetzen
deutschland müsste zumindest kurzfristig
auf mehr klimaschädlichen kohlestrom
setzen oder sogar die laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke verlängern auch ein
verzicht auf russisches öl wäre machbar
hätte aber auswirkungen auf die
spritpreise weil öl aus anderen ländern
importiert werden müsste so ist zb der
preis der nordseesorte brent seit dem
angriff russlands auf die ukraine um 15
prozent gestiegen es könnte weitergehen
es hat jetzt montag ein paar analysen
von investmentbanken gegeben die
prognostizieren einen ölpreis von bis zu
200 dollar da sind wir natürlich noch
weit von entfernt aber da wäre dann
theoretisch natürlich noch luft nach
oben das sich dann auch bei uns in den
heizöl- und benzinpreise niederschlagen
würde aber ich sehe dass momentan noch
nicht so wir haben insgesamt krisen
situation eigentlich immer ein auf und
ab bei den preisen und starke ausschläge
ein lieferstopp aus russland hätte
wirtschaftliche folgen so ökonomen der
universitäten köln und bonn kurzfristig
würde es zu einem rückgang des
bruttoinlandsprodukts zwischen minus 0,5
und minus drei prozent kommen die
verluste pro bürger reichen von 80 bis
1000 euro im jahr die nach szenario
käme es zum schlimmsten würden die öl
und gaslieferungen aus russland
ausbleiben dann hat die deutsche
wirtschaft massive schmerzen das heißt
wie geht in die rezession bekommen
dramatische inflationsraten und die
wirtschaft wird massiv schrumpfen das
heißt mehr arbeitslose das heißt auch
firmenpleiten das ist der preis der
batterie freiheit bezahlt werden müsste
viel hängt davon ab ob es zum äußersten
kommt also zu einem energie embargo mit
russland und die die ausfälle am
weltmarkt ersetzt werden können
der zuständige minister für all das ist
vizekanzler robert habeck jetzt bei uns
habe kunden am guten amt importstopp für
energie aus russland sofort fordert ein
breites bündnis aus der gesellschaft
heute da haben leute unterzeichnet den
sie politisch nahestehen können sie mit
dem gefühl leben diesen krieg am ende
mit zu finanzieren
wir treffen im moment alle
entscheidungen die harte konsequenzen
haben wir wissen dass eine große anzahl
von russischen soldaten gefallen sind
sicherlich auch durch waffen die wir
kürzlich freigegeben haben das sind
rationale entscheidungen die richtig
sind aber ob sie immer zum guten führen
das wird am ende zu entscheiden sein
natürlich und ich darf daran erinnern
dass ich immer gegen das team 2 war dass
ich die waffenlieferungen die ukraine
schon früher gefordert habe natürlich
will ich der ukraine helfen aber wir
können nur maßnahmen beschließen und ich
kann dir nur verantworten von denen ich
weiß dass wir sie auch durchhalten dass
sie nicht zu schweren wirtschaftlichen
schäden in deutschland führen und das
ist wäre der fall wenn wir jetzt öl
kohle und gas sofort nicht mehr in
dieses land lassen würden das heißt sie
müssen bin ich durch die verschiedenen
gewissen einfach mal moment zur seite
schieben weil es wirklich sehr schwere
schäden geben würde können sie uns diese
mal erläutern was sind denn diese
schweren schäden sie haben sogar von
schweren
gesamtgesellschaftlichen schäden
gesprochen nicht nur von schäden für die
wirtschaft eigentlich stehe in der
verantwortung für das ganze land das ist
meine aufgabe im moment und der diene
ich mit aller kraft die ich habe
zu ihrer frage wir wissen aus der kogit
pandemie dass der ausfall von nur
einigen vorprodukten zu schädigungen der
gesamten lieferkette führen kann und das
gilt natürlich auch für vorprodukte die
aus erdgas kohle oder öl stammen in
deutschland haben wir eine sonderheit
die beispielsweise die usa
großbritannien aber auch andere teile
von europa nicht haben wir sind durch
pipelinenetzes mit russland verbunden
ein großer teil der ölimporte kommt über
erdgebundene pipelines in ostdeutschland
an die raffinerieprodukte gehen dann
allerdings ins ganze land würden wir
darauf hat sie die sind eben nicht so
leicht durch schiffe zu ersetzen und
links arbeiten wir den ganzen tag 24
stunden sieben tage die woche daran
genau das zu tun mit einigem erfolg das
heißt wir werden uns schnell aus der
klammer von russischen importen befreien
aber noch sind wieder nicht was heißt
nun schnell aus der klammer von
russischen importen befreien ich meine
das ist jetzt über jahrzehnte versäumt
worden auf der einen seite aber
vielleicht sogar auch mit absicht so
gemacht worden eben weil es ein guter
deal war die energie aus russland zu
beziehen das kann man ja jetzt nicht in
den nächsten wochen und monaten alles
ändern oder doch doch in wochen und
monaten kann man es ändern aber nicht in
stunden und die wochen und monate
brauchen wir brauche ich um dann
entscheidungen auch zu verantworten die
nicht zu hunderttausenden von
arbeitslosen und zu preissprüngen führen
die menschen sich dann nicht mehr
leisten konnte herr becker das ist ja
gemein aber dann sagen sie uns was sie
da konkret ändern wollen die experten
die man dazu hört die sagen wir müssen
alle zum beispiel den gürtel enger
schnallen und es könnte sogar zu einem
absinken der wirtschaftsleistung in
deutschland fünf prozent sind da im
gespräch das wäre eine wirklich schlimme
rezession ist es das was was uns blüht
also ich will einmal sagen ich
bewundere alle menschen die jetzt sagen
dass sie bereit sind einschränkungen
hinzunehmen es geht aber bei den
entscheidungen die ich zu treffen habe
nicht um komfort einbußen im
individuellen bereich die sind
möglicherweise hinzunehmen hier geht es
darum wirtschaftliche schäden abzuwehren
die uns dann über jahre binden und auch
politisch lähmen werden fünf prozent
wirtschaftlicher einbruch wenn ist denn
so käme ist mehr als die kurve pandemie
und ich bin mir nicht sicher oder
irgendwas anders rum ich bin mir sicher
dass das geschehen dass wir dann zu
bewältigen hätten komplexer ist als die
kurve pandemie deswegen ist besonnenheit
und klugheit
die bedingung dafür dass man
verantwortung ausüben kann und das heißt
auch und es fällt mir selber ja total
schwer ich bin da ja emotional bei allen
menschen aber mein job ist im moment
nicht emotional zu handeln sondern
abgewogen informiert und so umsichtig
dass dieses land diese schwere zeit
bestehen kann um dann auch der ukraine
immer wieder helfen zu können
herr haben wir merken alle da gerät
etwas enorm ins wanken gerade aktuell es
soll jetzt verhandlungen mit dem
geächteten regime in venezuela geben und
anderen die bisher vollkommen
ausgeschlossen waren aus der
weltgemeinschaft die atomkraft soll
länger laufen sagen manche plötzlich
liegen neue hoffnungen auf den
klimakiller braunkohle es hieß immer
beim klimaschutz herbig jeder tag warten
ist ein tag zu viel gilt das jetzt noch
oder oder muss man salopp sagen putins
krieg ist noch schlimmer als die
klimakrise und beides bekommen wir
einfach nicht gestimmt
eigentlich würde nicht beides
miteinander gleichsetzen ist es in der
tat richtig dass die länder die jetzt
sagen wir trennen uns von putins öl
sagen dann nehmen wir gerne das öl aus
dem iran oder aus venezuela länder die
man da vorher auch die band hat also
ausgeschlossen hat von welthandel das
stimmt was allerdings den ausstieg aus
fossilen energien insgesamt angeht ist
diese krise sicherlich auch noch mal ein
mahnruf ein beschleuniger davor haben
wir diese transformation dieser
notwendigkeit unter klimaschutz
gesichtspunkten diskutiert
jetzt diskutieren wir sie auch endlich
unter sicherheitspolitischen
gesichtspunkten fossile energien stärken
immer monopole monopole stärken die
garten und oligarchen sind meistens für
wichtige gestalten
können befreien kommt doch jetzt sehr
viel zusammen wir hatten ja gesagt wir
können die klima wende schaffen wir
brauchen dafür aber gas und energie aus
russland jetzt haben wir das gas und
energie aus russland möglicherweise er
auch nicht mehr also es kommt doch jetzt
auf einmal alles zusammen und plötzlich
ist die braunkohle wieder im mittelpunkt
wenn die braunkohle ist überhaupt nicht
im mittelpunkt sie ist eine reserve
energie die wir im eigenen land haben
weil wir uns dagegen entschieden haben
in deutschland gas mit fracking aus dem
boden zu holen weil wir uns dagegen
entschieden haben steinkohle weiter
abzubauen weil es zu teuer ist
braunkohle machen wir noch aber es ist
die klimaschädlichste energieformen wir
halten sie nur vor als reservekapazität
werden kraftwerke rausgehen wir
versuchen den ausbau der erneuerbaren so
schnell wie es geht jetzt voranzutreiben
und ich sage voraus ich sitze irgendwann
wieder bei ihnen hier auf dem heißen
stuhl und sie werden mich fragen aber
habe ich was machen sie mit dem
gesellschaftlichen konsens die leute
wollen doch auch keine windkrafträder
haben im eigenen land ja aber irgendwas
werden wir brauchen müssen und das ist
die beste form und von nicht nur
russische land insgesamt am ende von
fossilen energien unabhängig zu machen
und auch hd zur braunkohle zu sagen
braunkohle ist nicht die antwort sie ist
nun das was wir im eigenen land noch
haben und dass wir schnell hinter uns
lassen können weil wir besseres haben
nämlich wind und sonne dann bis zum
nächsten mal robert habeck der
vizekanzler herzlichen dank für das
gespräch dankeschön
das gespräch aber aus termingründen eine
halbe stunde vor dieser sendung
aufgezeichnet der krieg gegen die
ukraine hat so viele folgen eine die zu
einer immer drängenderen herausforderung
für uns alle hier wird hat jetzt einen
blick
mittlerweile sollen mehr als 80.000
ukrainische geflüchtete in deutschland
angekommen seien und die verteilung der
kriegsflüchtlinge auf die bundesländer
soll künftig über hannover laufen
allerdings nicht nach einem starren
mechanismus dazu sagte niedersachsens
innenminister pistorius und gespräch mit
dem heute-journal update das
nachgesteuert werde wenn sich nach
einiger zeit herausstelle dass die
belastung für die bundesländer sehr
ungleich verteilt ist das ganze gespräch
im update um 0 uhr 45
das us-verteidigungsministerium hat sich
gegen den vorschlag polens ausgesprochen
der ukraine indirekt über eine us-basis
mehrere mig-29 kampfjet zu überlassen
dies dürfte auch thema beim besuch von
us-vizepräsident in harris in polen sein
für morgen sind gespräche mit dem
polnischen ministerpräsidenten duda
geplant und das kanzler scholz hatte
sich ebenfalls gegen die lieferung der
kampfflugzeuge ausgesprochen
die eu hat weitere sanktionen gegen
russland und belarus verhängt drei bälle
russische banken werden aus dem
zahlungssystem swift ausgeschlossen
zudem wird unter anderem die ausfuhr von
schifffahrt ausrüstung verboten und es
wurden vorschriften zu crypto währungen
ergänzt um bisherige schlupflöcher zu
schließen gleichzeitig zeigen die
bisherigen sanktionen bereits wirkung
mit deutlichen wirtschaftlichen folgen
für russland fragen wir nach bei frank
bethmann an der frankfurter börse heute
wurde die kreditwürdigkeit russlands
noch weiter herabgestuft auf
ramschniveau ja genau diese nur noch
minderwertige kreditwürdigkeit hat
enorme auswirkungen für alle die dem
land geld geliehen haben also investoren
und gläubiger über nacht halten sie
hochriskante papiere der hand ist tot
der totalausfall konkret geht es um 49
milliarden dollar die russland an
staatsanleihen in dollar und euro offen
hat nächste woche werden dafür
zinszahlungen von 100 millionen dollar
fällig die moskauer aber wohl nicht wird
auszahlen können hauptverantwortlich
dafür die westlichen sanktionen gegen
das land russland kommt nicht mehr an
seine devisen im ausland an dollars und
euros diese vermögenswerte sind
eingefroren und so drohen den gläubigern
darunter auch deutschen banken
empfindliche zahlungsausfälle
gleichzeitig zogen sich heute mit der
weltgrössten kaffeekette starbucks mit
coca cola und pepsi sowie mit mcdonald's
gleich vier große marken die auch
russland teilweise über jahrzehnte
prägten aus dem land zurück zu groß war
offenbar der öffentliche druck geworden
nachdem diese konzerne zu verzögerten
ihren geschäftsbetrieb dort einzustellen
alles andere als zögerlich heute der dax
über 1000 punkte an einem einzigen tag
kann das börsenbarometer zulegen wann
hat es das schon mal gegeben
doch der jubel hält sich in grenzen an
anderen tagen hätte man sich sicher mehr
darüber gefreut vielen dank
so fiel zunächst zum thema ukraine da
war doch noch was nennt sich corona und
wir können das thema nicht aus den augen
lassen auch wenn wir das alle
miteinander sicherlich gerne würden in
zehn tagen laufen in deutschland alle
corona maßnahmen aus aber doch nicht so
ganz denn die infektionszahlen steigen
wieder und die regierung hat sich heute
auf einen gesetzentwurf geeinigt an
sogenannten basisschutz soll es weiter
geben und dazu gehören masken pflicht
den altenheimen und krankenhäusern
masken pflicht im öffentlichen
nahverkehr und testpflicht in schulen
härtere maßnahmen darüber hinaus liegen
dann künftig komplett in der
entscheidung der einzelnen bundesländer
auch dass wenn man so will eine
zeitenwende daniel johnston berichtet
zwei jahre lang bestimmten
bund-länder-treffen das bild nach dem
entwurf zum neuen infektionsschutzgesetz
entscheiden die länder künftig nun
weitgehend selbst wie sie vorgehen wenn
das infektionsgeschehen wieder steigt in
sogenannten regionalen hotspots ein
hotspot das ist eine region wo entweder
eine hohe inzidenz
beobachtet wird oder wo die inzidenz
stark steigt und die
krankenhausversorgung bedroht ist oder
aber wo eine neue variante an der
gefährliche neue variante beobachtet
wird der bund stellt für diese fälle nur
noch mögliche maßnahmen bereit den
sogenannten instrumentenkasten und der
betrieb noch enthalten etwa masken
pflicht in öffentlichen räumen zwei oder
drei die regeln als
zugangsbeschränkungen oder pflicht zur
hygiene konzepten doch welche maßnahmen
dann konkret ergriffen werden
entscheiden die länder in ihren
parlamenten selbst und vor allem ob
überhaupt den konkrete hotspot
schwellenwerte gibt es nicht mehr eine
bestimmte hospitalisierung rate etwa
oder intensivbetten belegung
ausdrücklich keine zahlen genannt aus
medizinischer sicht machen die keinen
sinn es kommt sehr darauf an welche
variante wir hier also bekämpfen müssen
also man muss wirklich das gesamtbild
sehen also war wie es die situation in
den krankenhäusern
wie ist die dynamik des
krankheitsgeschehens
auch definieren die länder selbst wie
groß ein solcher hotspot ist sprich ob
die maßnahmen in einem stadtteil gelten
einer ganzen stadt einem landkreis oder
gar im ganzen bundesland der hotspot das
ist ja die formulierung und auch der
wunsch der länder gewesen und auch der
richtige gesundheits fachliche aspekt
dass wenn wir eine besondere
gefahrensituation haben dann muss es
auch mehr maßnahmen geben können und
genau das leistet die hotspot regierung
mit diesem rahmen erfüllt die
bundesregierung eine kernforderung die
ihr expertenrat gestern formuliert hatte
dennoch gibt es teils scharfe kritik
auch aus den ampel parteien selbst die
reduzierung der instrumente jetzt sei
grob fahrlässig so winfried kretschmann
schwer zu verstehen findet es stephan
weil auch die union fordert
nachbesserungen
die minister verteidigen ihr paket sehen
darin auch kein signal zu vollständige
öffnung wenn es so
kommen sollte dass die den fallzahlen
und wieder steigen und somit auch die
kliniken also eine deutliche zunahme der
last zu tragen haben sie es ja jetzt
schon nicht gering dann also würde
natürlich das instrumentarium was wir
hier gerade vorgestellt haben würde
sofort greifen deshalb gehen wir jetzt
diesen schritt und sind uns da auch
einig dass das der verhältnismäßige und
angemessenen schritt in der lage ist wie
sie jetzt besteht die fraktionen können
noch änderungsvorschläge machen sollte
der bundestag das gesetz der nächste
woche beschließen bräuchte es aber keine
zustimmung vom bundesrat mehr betonte
lauterbach das gesetz würde dann gelten
mindestens bis zu einer neubewertung im
herbst
in österreich wird die eingeführte
impfpflicht vorerst wieder ausgesetzt
zur begründung hieß es dass die
impfpflicht bei der vorherrschenden
omikron variante nicht verhältnismäßig
sei die entscheidung soll in drei
monaten erneut überprüft werden
österreich hatte als erstes eu-land
anfang februar eine impfpflicht ab 18
jahren eingeführt
die bundesregierung will das werbeverbot
für abtreibung abschaffen und hat dazu
einen gesetzentwurf auf den weg gebracht
der § 209 10 a soll ersatzlos gestrichen
werden dadurch soll erreicht werden dass
ärzte in zukunft auch über die methoden
von schwangerschaftsabbrüchen
informieren dürfen bisher mussten sie in
diesem fall strafverfolgung fürchten
bundestag und bundesrat müssen noch
zustimmen
die holocaust-überlebende und autorin
inge deutschkron ist im alter von 99
jahren gestorben
die jüdische zeitzeugin besuchte
unzählige schulen um über ihre
überlebensgeschichte zu berichten und
schrieb außerdem ein buch darüber
während der ns zeit konnte sich deutsch
krone zusammen mit ihrer mutter vor dem
nazis verstecken
jetzt noch der blick auf die lottozahlen
sie lauten 8 18 19 28 36 38 und die
superzahl 4 alle angaben wie immer ohne
gewähr
gleich nach und zeigt das
auslandsjournal wie junge russen aus
angst verhaftet zu werden jetzt ihre
heimat verlassen dass gleich nach und
wir wünschen ihnen jetzt einen schönen
abend noch
[Musik]
beamte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter vergleichen wir den vergangenen
winter den vergangenen meteorologischen
winter mit den wintern zuvor mit den
jahren zuvor und das ist die grafik vom
deutschen wetterdienst die alle winter
seit
1882 bis in die gegenwart zeigt und der
letzte balken nächste winter
2021/2022 und was man hier erkennt ist
vor allem dass die letzten elf jahre die
letzten elf winter zu warm waren
deutlich zu warm und insgesamt steigt
die temperatur
tendenziell in den wintermonaten weiter
an wir schauen auf das aktuelle wetter
und gut seit zwei wochen haben wir hohem
luftdruck und dieses hoch hier das baut
sich weiter auf 4.040 hektopascal
erreichen auf seiner ostseite kommt
eisige luft bis in die türkei runter und
bei uns mildere luft und so steigt die
temperatur morgen bis auf 16 grad
schauen wir in die nacht gratis
größtenteils auf einzig richtung ostsee
ist es mal bewölkter und das bei
tiefsten temperaturen von minus sieben
grad an den alpen und -5 grad im osten
deutschlands nach westen plus ein grad
morgen daran viel sonnenschein einzig im
osten mal harmlose wolken insgesamt
weiterhin trockenes wetter bei höchsten
temperaturen von sieben grad an der
ostsee und 16 grad im westen
deutschlands
die kommenden tage bleiben sonnig und
trocken am freitag 6 bis 15 grad sonntag
sogar bis 16 grad damit ein schöner ab